why you
L and you
CH and you try to make full L of
[Applause]
[Music]
sh
so with Guardians of the Galaxy coming
out in the next few days Benny and I
have come up with this idea to
effectively split Ron and the accuser in
half in order to have this sort of
Marvel crossover event and what we're
going to do is we're going to discuss
the history the origin so to speak of
Ron and the accuser here on my channel
and we're going to discuss the origins
of the cre Empire how it was the cre
Empire Advanced itself as well as the
motives and the basis behind the being
the Supreme intelligence from there
we'll transition over to Ben's Channel
and we'll get into a discussion about
the annihilation storyline about Ron and
the accuser during the events after the
formation of the Guardians of the Galaxy
and his role regarding the bigger
picture when it comes to the universe as
a whole and his place in the cre Empire
but in order to understand the entire
backstory behind Ron and the accuser in
order to understand why it is that he
does what he does we need to go back to
the origins of the Creed we need to jump
back to when the cree first rose to
prominence in the Empire as well as the
earliest formations and what would
eventually turn into the Supreme
[Music]
intelligence so the origins of the cre
are first given to us in Captain Marvel
volume 1 issue number 38 and what we
learn here is that in the infancy of the
the cre Empire that they shared their
planet with another race called the
kotti and while the cre were very
humanoid in terms of their physical
appearance with the exception of the
fact that they had blue skin uh what we
saw was that the kotti were very
plant-like in their appearance and in
fact the kotti for the most part could
best be compared to Groot from Guardians
of the Galaxy with the exception of the
fact that where Groot looks more like a
tree in terms of his physical appearance
that the kotti are very Lush and very
green and resemble more along the order
of plants or bushes but what we see is
that the scroll Empire which was very
fledgling at the time it was expanding
and it was growing was seeking to add
various races to itself to uh help it
expand into the world of trade and
commerce and that the Scrolls had come
across the home planet Hala of the cre
and the uh the kotti and what they did
is while they were interested in giving
one of these races a chance to join the
Empire they gave them a test more or
less and what they did is they took both
races to the Moon of the planet Earth
and they gave them a Year's worth of
supplies and they gave them the
opportunity to effectively use those
supplies to build whatever they would
need to make themselves self
self-sufficient and after a year's time
the Scrolls returned and the Scrolls
found that the kotti had built this very
Lush environment they had built this
very welcoming sort of environment and
that the cre had used their technology
to build a very uh beautiful and a very
um I guess Advanced kind of um Castle or
Fortress so to speak due to the fact
that the Scrolls at the time were a
peaceful race they Allied themselves
with the kotti and chose to induct the
kotti into their empire in response to
this the creek killed all of almost all
of the kotti on the moon as well as the
uh the scroll delegation which had
arrived to pass judgment on the two
races from there the cre had reverse
engineered the technology of the Scrolls
and began to advance themselves at a
very very rapid rate now in Avengers
volume 3 issue number 35 the story
continues although it takes place
several thousand years or possibly even
more after the original uh incident
involving the the the cre and the kotti
and what we learned is that somewhere
along the line the cre began to run into
evolutionary stagnation meaning that
they were not uh evolving anymore and so
in response to this the Supreme
intelligence launched this sort of um I
guess war or launch this sort of
conflict with the sh between the cre and
the shiar itself and the shiar empire in
turn detonated something called the
negga bomb and this was entirely
motivated by the Supreme intelligence
the Supreme intelligence had
rationalized that if the Nega bomb or if
some kind of conflict came along that
virtually rendered the entire uh cre
race almost to the point of
non-existence that uh they would begin
to uh evolve again their evolutionary
process would be jump started this was
also further enhanced by the Supreme
intelligence when it used something
called the forever Crystal
but what we saw is that where previously
the cre had begun to evolve or had
evolved with uh involving humanoids with
blue skin that a new version of the cre
called the rule began to evolve and this
is where we run into the hierarchical
differences between the cre in terms of
their own society that the cre have this
inherent this original Society those
individuals that could trace their
lineage back to the original cre who had
blue skin those individuals are
considered part of the aristocratic
Society meaning that they are part of
the Inner Circle they are the only ones
that are really allowed to hold the
higher positions that are available in
the cre Empire everybody else who is
able to trace their lineage back to a
rule is viewed as being lesser than that
they are simply just common citizens and
from here we get into this discussion
where we talk about the Supreme
intelligence where we talk about what it
is that Supreme intelligence does and
the entire basis behind the Supreme
[Music]
intelligence
so when the cre Supreme intelligence
first appeared in the Marvel universe is
a date that we really can't put our
fingers on or at least to the best of my
research is not a date that we could
specifically point to but all we really
know is that somewhere along the line
the cre began to use their uh technology
to connect or to form a hive mind out of
the greatest Minds to have ever existed
in the cre Empire and that as the eons
passed that more and more Minds were
added to this sueme intelligence hive
mind and this is the entire basis behind
the Supreme intelligence the Supreme
intelligence is an amalgamation of all
the greatest Minds who have ever existed
in the cre Empire and that as the years
go on and that as various uh individuals
who are great in their own right begin
to rise up that when their time comes
when they die that their mind will be
added to the Supreme intelligence and
the Supreme intelligence will maintain
this role of being the spiritual and
political leader of the cre Empire now
just because the Supreme intelligence is
an amalgamation of the greatest Minds
doesn't mean that it cannot go arai but
over the course of Marvel Comics in
terms of the publication histories and
the Supreme intelligence we don't really
see this happening very often for the
most part the Supreme intelligence
exists to one ensure its own Survival
and two to ensure the survival of the
cre Empire and in one of the most most
notable events if you recall our
discussion about the Inhumans we had
talked about how the Inhumans were
designed by the cre to effectively be
soldiers to take on various forms once
they had undergone penesis and their
forms would be used to infiltrate uh
various races and of course this is
something that we will touch on later
again in this video as we continue our
discussion on Ron and the accuser and
his role regarding the Inhumans but what
we had learned is that in the origins in
the initial creation of the metagenesis
project which was the project that led
to the creation of the Inhumans that one
of the minds of the Supreme intelligence
had determined that there would be
descent that at some point along the
line one one of these projects would
begin to rise up against the cre Empire
and that it would result in the
destruction of the Supreme intelligence
but the problem here is that the Supreme
intelligence was only able to calculate
this to a 90% 90 percentile and so as a
result all that 10% of the metagenesis
project was destroyed and of this 10%
this included the Inhumans of the planet
Earth and again this is simply just the
uh the Supreme intelligence carrying out
its design to ensure that it surviv Liv
along with the cre Empire even if that
means destroying the projects that the
cre Empire had formed over the years now
from here we begin to transition into
the Fantastic Four and we begin to get
into seeing the cre Empire seeing the
Supreme intelligence and seeing Ron and
the accuser up here and one of the
things that we'll learn here is that Ron
and the accuser isn't necessarily a bad
guy that Ron and the accuser's role as
the accuser or the head of the accuser
corpse which is the law enforcement
agency of the cre Empire and is designed
to carry out the will of the Supreme
intelligence that rodne the accuser is
in fact doing just that that he is a
perfect example of this argument of a
person who is in effect just following
[Music]
orders so the Supreme intelligence and
ronning the accuser first appear here in
Fantastic 4 volume 1 issue number 65 but
in order to make this comic make sense
we actually need to touch on the
previous comic on issue number 6 4
because the events in that comic will
directly lead into the events of issue
number 65 and give us the understanding
of why it is that Ron and the accuser
and why it is that the Supreme
intelligence have both been given to us
and why Ron and the accuser is traveling
to the planet Earth so with Fantastic 4
issue number 64 what we see going on
here is that Reed Richards and Ben Grim
have been working tirelessly over the
course of spring to ensure that uh
various Technologies and that various
defense systems are up to Snuff in the
backer building but Susan storm is a
little irritated by this due to the fact
that it is spring and Susan storm wants
to take a vacation Reed Richards is a
little hesitant about this because he
rationalizes that uh there will always
be threats and that the backr building
needs to be at the highest level of
operation in order to ensure that
threats both to the back building and
the Fantastic for themselves as well as
the Earth as a whole can be uh staved
off or they can at the very least be
held off to ensure that no harm really
comes to anybody but Susan storm begin
to argue with Reed Richards and again
this touches on the Hallmark of the
Fantastic 4 in the sense that the
Fantastic 4 were the first superhero
team to really argue and to really give
us an idea of or I guess a reflection of
what family life is like in Marvel
Comics and again is a reflection of real
life family life but what we see going
on is that Reed Richards Ben grim and
Johnny Storm acques to Susan storm and
they agree to uh to go on a vacation of
sorts what we also see going on here is
that on a remote island somewhere off
the coast of to the Atlantic I think um
that a archaeologist and a Hired Gun who
of course has been hired to ensure this
archaeologist safety are exploring this
island and the whole reason for this is
because this archaeologist had come
across evidence to show that
extraterrestrials had visited the planet
Earth in the past now this archaeologist
doesn't know about the Inhumans and he
doesn't know that this extraterrestrial
race was the cre but his explorations
have led him to this island to some sort
of Temple or safe place or whatever the
case may be
uh to give him a chance to investigate
and give him a chance to explore but
what we see is that when this area is
activated that he unwillingly or
unwittingly activates the century and
the century is one of the cre centuries
that had been stationed on the planet
Earth and if you recall our discussion
about the Inhumans we had talked about
how U I guess after the cre had left the
planet Earth they had left behind
various centuries and these centuries
were designed to execute a number of uh
of programs that had been installed in
them some of of the centries were
designed to monitor the cre to I'm sorry
the Inhumans and to report back to the
cre the progress of the Inhumans and
others were given different tasks and
this cre in particular cre number 459
was actually given the task of
safeguarding this island to ensure that
nobody trespassed but because of the
fact this archaeologist and The Hired
Gun have trespassed that this uh cre
Century immediately imprisons them from
here we transition back to the Fantastic
4 and the Fantastic 4 are again enjoying
their vacation they have arrived on the
island but almost immediately after
arriving they encounter this cre century
and the cre Century again attempts to
ens snare them attempts to trap them for
trespassing on the island the Fantastic
Four respond in kind in a manner of
self-defense and begin to attack the cre
centry and over the course of this
combat what we see is that eventually
the Sentry is destroyed as a result of
this we pick up with Fantastic 4 issue
number 65 and what we see is that the
Supreme intelligence sends the fantastic
for a dream and tells the Fantastic 4
that they have to await the arrival of
Ron and the accuser to stand for their
crimes to of destroying the century
which is viewed as an affront to the cre
Empire from here we see that Ron and the
accuser is traveling to the planet Earth
and Ron and the accuser is talking about
how during The grae Purge that we had
previously talked about during the uh
discussion on the Supreme intelligence
whereby 90% of the entire metagenesis
project was destroyed that the Earth had
been forgotten and that no one had
really thought about the Earth up until
these events and that the destruction of
the cre Century raises two main points
the first is that it's possible that the
metagenesis project has allowed the
humans who were experimented on to
progress to such a degree that they can
now be used as soldiers in the cre Army
but the other half of this is that
perhaps the metagenesis project did not
work but there are still superhumans on
the planet Earth and those superhumans
can be used but the first and foremost
role of ronin the accuser and his
arrival on the planet Earth is to carry
out the will to carry out the Judgment
of the Supreme
intelligence that the Fantastic Four
have been found guilty of in effect a
fronting the cre Empire we see that when
Ron and the accuser arrives that of
course he confronts the Fantastic Four
and his First Act is to change the
Fantastic Force clothing from their
street clothes to their uniforms and
this is done using his Universal Weapon
and the Universal Weapon is of course
the weapon that is designed specifically
for the head accuser or the top of the
top accuser which uh Ron and the accuser
currently resides in and that the
Universal Weapon has a multitude of
effects the most common form that Ron
and the accuser uses it for is either
flight force fields or energy projection
but the Universal Weapon can also be
used for matter manipulation now this is
a matter manipulation on the scale of
Franklin Richards is actually much much
smaller but it's still very formidable
in its own right and allows Ron and the
accuser to become one of the more
formidable people in the Marvel Universe
in terms of his fighting prowess and the
abilities that he possesses in addition
we see that Ron and the accuser does
this simply to demonstrate the fact that
he he has or he views himself as being
uh over the Fantastic for that he has
designed he has done this to Simply
establish his Supremacy so to speak and
we begin to see that the Fantastic Fort
and Ron and the accuser begin to fight
one another now what Ron and the accuser
had also done here is he had also in
effect created a force field around this
island and the whole reason for that was
to ensure that no external forces could
interfere with the Judgment that's being
presided over the Fantastic 4 as the
conflict progresses we see that the
Fantastic 4 are for the most part able
to hold their own against Ron and the
accuser but Ron and the accuser is also
able to hold his own own as well which
is actually quite impressive considering
that it's the full might of the
Fantastic Four versus one man but
ultimately we see that Ben Grim is able
to take Ron and the accuser's uh actions
his attempt at passing judgment on the
Fantastic Four and turn it on Ron and
the accuser now all this really means is
that Ron and the accuser appears to have
been prepared to deal the to deal the
killing blow now we don't know if it
would have actually killed the Fantastic
Four we assume that it will since that's
usually the role that Ron and the
accuser plays but for the most part he
is in fact defeated by The Fantastic
Four but what we see is that Ron and the
accuser simply just disappears we don't
really know where he went to but we're
for the most part left to presume that
Ron and the accuser had traveled back to
the Supreme intelligence to inform him
not only of his failure to implement his
judgment or the Judgment of the uh the
Supreme Intelligence on the Fantastic 4
but that the Fantastic 4 themselves are
quite formidable of an enemy and that
the planet Earth may also inhabit other
superheroes who are equally formidable
or even more
[Music]
so so after running the accuser's
appearance in the Fantastic 4 issue
number 65 in volume 1 we see that for
the most part Ron and the accuser will
now be relegated to the role of
appearing periodically in Captain Marvel
stories as well as Silver Surfer and
Other Stories that take place on a
galactic scale he'll appear periodically
in The Avengers but for the most part
most of his experiences or most of his
appearances will take place in Captain
Marvel and this makes sense because
Marvel is in effect a cre and his
initial place his initial idea was to
Simply travel to the planet Earth as a
spy for the cre after the results of uh
of the Fantastic Four defeating rod and
the accuser but that he would actually
turn against the Kore Empire and join
the superhero community on the planet
Earth and what we see for the most part
is that when Ronin the accuser appears
in Captain marvell's Comics that his
goal is into is to effect uh Implement
Justice on Captain Marvell to attempt to
capture him and um the attempt to force
him to stand punishment for his actions
of betraying the cre Empire most more
often than not he's not successful in
fact Captain Marvel seems to get away
every single time but at the very least
it's simply just a chance for us to see
more of Ron and the accuser and for the
most part we see Ron and the accuser
playing roles that are very similar to
the same role that he played during the
Fantastic for where he demonstrates in
the beginning of the conflict his power
and his ability to implement Justice on
uh on behalf of the cre Empire and the
power that he wields using the Universal
Weapon but we also see that Ron and the
accuser even without the Universal
Weapon is quite formidable in terms of
his abilities and in terms of what it is
that he's capable of doing that without
the Universal Weapon he is still a very
uh capable hand hand combatant that he
is a very capable leader and he is very
capable in being able to Rally troops
together for a particular cause one of
the more notable story lines involving
Ron and the accuser after the events of
Fantastic 4 issue number 65 comes during
Inhumans volume 3 and for the most part
this is a four-part series it's actually
a very limited run and what we see here
is that Ron and the accuser returns to
planet Earth to capture the Inhumans
from a tillin and the whole basis for
this is ronen the accuser is in effect
trying to to force the Inhumans to
fulfill the role to which they were
initially designed that the Inhumans
when they were created were designed to
uh infiltrate other races which is the
reason why the Inhumans take on various
forms when they undergo terragenesis and
that rod and the accuser has in effect
kidnapped the Inhumans and is trying to
put them in a position where they will
be subservient to him now over the
course of this four-part limited series
we of course see that uh blackbolt
challenges Ron and the accuser to combat
and that if Ron and the accuser is
successful then the the Inhumans will
acques and the Inhumans will serve the
cre Empire but that if blackbolt is
successful that the Inhumans will be
allowed to go free of course over the
course of this conflict we see that
blackbolt appears to be losing but at
the end of the story we see that he is
successful in defeating Ron and the
accuser and the Inhumans are allowed to
go about their way from here we're going
to transition over to Benny's Channel
and we're going to talk about Ron and
the accuser after the events of the
Inhumans volume one or volume three
rather and we're going to be talking
about Ron and the accuser during and
after the events of annihilation
following into Annihilation Conquest the
war of Kings as well as
[Music]
Infinity believe did you the word find
me I kept the feelings really thought it
cost me drops in goggles aren't of Love
something's really wrong and it feels
awful and even though nobody is back to
normal she